λαταχω στα συρτάρια υ υπίση δεν είναι κάτι το οποίο δυστυχώς διαβάζεται από ολούς θεωρείται
οτειδύσχολοη οι άσχετι ι περδμένοι καπι αφορα εμπάση περιπτώσει όμως υπάρχουν παραπολύπιτς που γράφουν στα
ηλεβικά και αυτό είναι καλό υπάρχει κτι που χαλαρώνει των κυριοπι κάηδιάρκεια της μέρας μέσα
σεαυτό το μαριφοτωμένοπρόγραμμα του που δεν ξέρω πωστέ ρες ώρες πως τανών αλλά υπάρχει κάνι
κυρεπιτθα πό σα χαλαρών είναι κάτι το οποίο θέλετε να κάνετ έτσι όστε ναφαλαρώσετα λίγο
οι τεχνοι και ιλογοτεχνία κυι κυρίως και οταλεοιτεχνισγραφική τεχνοι και ληπτική αλλά ενδιαφέρουμε κυρίως η
απαλαιότερες εποχές χωρίς να αποκλίο και τη δική μας εποχή η οποία καταδιγνώημου σεωρισμένες περιπτώσης
έχει ξεπέση λίγο αλλά συνεχς βλέπω να γενιούνται αρκετά χαρισματικοί καλιτεχνες και στην κύπρο και
στην ελάρα για να τελειώσουμε αυτή τη συζήτηση όπως στη ξακινήσαμε με το χεμί και
στο όχει της εταιρείας για τα μελωντικά πλάναοσιαστικά τόσο στην κύπροσοκαι στο εξωτερικό τα απελοδικά
πλάνοφυσικά είναι οι επόμενοι και για ευτυχώς έχω τρια παιδιά και η νεόλι μαζί μου
ι το σύμφυμα είναι